here's what would happen if you were  attacked by a Megalodon  let's say you're on a boat with its 34  metric ton body the Meg would Ram you  from underneath flipping your boat and  destroying it with your boat completely  wrecked you'd be in the water if you  happen to get a cut during this process  the Megalodon would be able to find you  with its Keen sense of smell your best  bet would be to remain calm and start  swimming to Shore or another boat if you  made it to shallow Waters then your  chances of survival would be even better  since the Megalodon is so massive it  wouldn't be able to maneuver in Shallow  Waters but realistically if you were  anywhere near this massive Beast you'd  quickly become its food I mean come on  it's the Megalodon it could probably  gobble you up in one bite so thank  goodness they're extinct because